what role was your wife in this
situation because she came in very sweet
lady introduce yourself she says Hi I'm
the liver Queen yeah I go oh damn
so I'm
must have known what you were doing
um that's my assumption I'll let you
answer that obviously I'll say two
things about that because yeah earlier
when you're like okay who do you have
around you that's better than you and I
don't really want to share publicly who
that is but I'll share publicly that
there's no doubt um that my wife is
number one you know when I knew her when
I first met her I knew she was way
better than me she's still way better
than me
um you know we got this thing in our
household loyalty above all that comes
from her you know you come home with a
dead body
that person helps you to figure out how
to bury it right and then you talk about
the ethical and moral quandary later and
you deal with that internally
um what I'll tell you is that um I've
never lied to my wife my wife knows
about this
um we're dealing with that internally as
well